-Ce sera beau l'An 2000 ?
-Oui.
-Tu es content d'aller vivre
l'An 2000 ?
-Oui.
-Tu auras 50 ans.
Comment ça va être ?
-Tout aura changé, déjà.
-Ce sera le luxe.
J'aurai une maison,
des terrasses, des piscines.
-Les maisons voleront.
-On aura
des cuirasses en fer...
Et puis,
..les trains auront des ailes,
..auront des réacteurs
et ils voleront.
-Ce sera magnifique.
-L'An 2000,
je vois avec des souterrains,
..beaucoup de grattes-ciels.
Et les voitures
passeront sous terre.
-Et les gens,
comment sont-ils ?
-Ils seront habillés
comme dans l'ancien temps.
-Ce sera bien, l'An 2000 ?
-Oui, ce sera bien.
-Tu en penses quoi
de l'An 2000 ?
-Ce sera plus moderne,
tout sera changé.
-Ce sera sûrement très différent
du monde actuel.
La technique va prendre
de plus en plus d'expansion,
..et va agir
sur de nombreux domaines.
-D'après vous,
ce sera beau l'An 2000 ?
-Je ne conçois pas du tout
l'An 2000, puisque maintenant..
..le monde
n'est pas très beau à voir,
..toutes ces guerres,
les événements de maintenant.
-Pourquoi ce ne sera pas beau ?
-Il y aura des maisons partout.
-Tu en vois des coins de verdure ?
-Non, pas du tout.
-L'An 2000 c'est irréel,
..parce que..
..j'ai peur de devenir vieille,
..et j'aurai 54 ans en l'An 2000.
Je n'espère pas les avoir,
..mais si je les ai, j'essaierai
de vivre avec mon temps.
Je suppose que le progrès
sera déjà bien loin..
..de ce qu'il y a maintenant.
Et j'espère qu'on aura fait..
..beaucoup de choses
pour les enfants,
..qu'on leur donnera..
..un enseignement plus pratique..
..que maintenant.
Pour le progrès, ce sera...
Heu...
Quelque chose qui deviendra
un peu inhumain, qui sera encore..
..plus loin que nous que
ce que l'on fait maintenant.
C'est pour ça que
l'An 2000 me fait peur.
-En tous cas, ce sera plus
agréable que le 20e siècle,
..que notre époque actuelle.
Les maisons,
..même si ce sont encore
des grands immeubles,
..seront vitrées.
Les rues,
on y pénétrera librement.
Et ils seront
plus agréable à habiter..
..que certaines...
Que certaines cités
d'immeubles,
..maintenant intenables.
-Comment tu vois les maisons ?
-Rondes.
-Et sur quoi tiennent-elles ?
-Sur la terre.
-Je vois des immeubles
en plastique.
Avec des gros blocs de plastiques.
Ils qui les assembleront,
qui seront soudées.
-Pour moi, les maisons seront
des grandes immeubles en verre,
..un peu comme au port
de Rotterdam, ou Amsterdam...
-Tu vois la ville comme ça ?
-Oui,
..mais avec des arbres
et assez espacé les immeubles.
-Comment sera
ta maison d'ouvrier ?
-Elle sera dans un gratte-ciel,
car il n'y aura plus de pavillon,
..plus de petits immeubles...
-Tu seras très haut ?
-Ca dépend de la hauteur...
-Tu auras envie de quoi ?
-Ne pas tomber.
-Vous savez, les maisons...
Avec tous les taudis qu'il y a,
..j'ignore si on peut envisager
des belles maisons en l'An 2000.
-Comment seront les rues
autour des maisons ?
-Il n'y aura pas beaucoup,
il y aura des petites rues.
-Où se passera la circulation ?
-Dans le ciel.
-Il faudra atterir où ?
-Les toits seront plats.
On pourra circuler sur les toits,
..puis dans les rues.
-Le véhicule sera
une espèce de voiture..
..avec des formes assez pointues..
..qui avancera
sur un coussin d'air.
-Et que vois-tu comme carburant ?
-Du carburant
qu'on trouvera sur la lune.
-Tu vois un véhicule pour l'avenir ?
-Oui, une espèce de petite sphère,
..avec une bille, à la base,
qui tournerait comme on veut,
..puis ça grimperait partout.
Et ça irait aussi
dans les airs.
-Vois-tu une vie extérieure
à la planète Terre ?
-Oui, mais...
Ca me paraît très possible, puisque
maintenant il y a des astronautes.
Mais c'est effrayant.
-Pourquoi ?
-Parce que...
Les hommes ne seront plus
des hommes.
Ils seront devenus des hommes
qui vont dans la lune.
-Je crois qu'il y aura
tout de même une...
Une coopération pacifique..
..dans la conquête de la lune
et des autres planètes.
Mais je ne vois
certainement pas..
..une lutte sur la terre
pour la conquête de l'espace.
Je crois que...
celui qui découvrira
ou qui mettra le premier..
..le pied sur une planète,
sera sur la possession.
-Il y aura sûrement
la guerre avec les Martiens...
Des sortes de planète.
-Tu vois des planètes extérieures ?
-Oui.
-Comment vois-tu
ton voyage dans la lune ?
Imagine que tu fasses ton service
militaire dans un groupe astral.
Comment te vois-tu habiller
et comment vois-tu ta vie ?
-On sera habillés
avec des combinaisons..
..anti-radiation atomique,
des choses comme ça.
-Qui se battra, des hommes
avec d'autres hommes d'ailleurs ?
-Oui.
-Tu as peur de la guerre ?
-Non.
-Tu crois qu'il y aura la guerre ?
-Oui.
-Tu feras quoi, toi ?
-Je ne sais pas,
je resterai sûrement ici.
-Et tu ferais un soldat ?
-Bien sûr.
-Et ça te fais pas peur ?
-Non.
Ca ne me fais pas peur
maintenant,
..mais quand j'y serai,
ça me fera peut-être un peu peur.
-La guerre ne pourra
sans doute pas être supprimée.
Si la technique
ne s'agit pas les hommes,
..et va dans le sens
de la violence,
..il est certain que les guerres
prendront de plus en plus d'ampleur.
-Le progrès te fais peur ?
-Oui et non.
Le progrès donne
une nette amélioration,
..sans doute
dans la vie de l'homme,
..de tous les hommes.
Mais il peut conduire
à des excès..
..qui se termineront par la guerre.
-Qu'est-ce qu'il te fais peur
dans l'avenir ?
-Ce qu'il me fais le plus peur,
..c'est le manque de modération
que peuvent avoir les hommes.
Ils ne sauront peut-être pas
contenir tout ce qu'ils trouveront.
-Il y aura la fin du monde,
si il y a la guerre maintenant,
..avec les bombes qui existent.
-Tu n'aimerais pas être soldat ?
-Non, non, non.
-Ce serait terrible,
parce que...
Comme on serait certainement..
..dans l'air atomique,
..si les gens se font la guerre,
..ils détruiront tout.
-Je trouve, au contraire,
qu'il n'y aura plus de guerre.
-Les moyens de destruction
seront tels que, finalement,
..la guerre ne sera plus possible.
-Je crois que vers l'An 2000,
..l'Europe sera ou aura tendance
à s'unifier.
L'Europe, peut-être le monde,
..s'il est prouvé
que nous aurons à faire..
..à d'autres vies, à d'autres
sociétés, dans la planète.
-Peut-être une union
des Etats de l'Europe.
En tous cas,
une égalité dans tous les pays.
Qu'il y ait une puissance égale,
un équilibre sur toute la terre.
-Comment vois-tu
les gouvernements ?
-Des gouvernements démocratiques,
..et qui feront régner la paix.
-Tu ne veux pas faire
de la politique ?
Tu crois que ce n'est pas utile ?
-Non, ça ne m'intéresse pas.
-Je ne sais pas comment ça sera,
mais je voudrais qu'on soit libres,
..qu'on puisse s'exprimer
comme on veut,
..qu'il n'y ait pas
de différence de classe...
Enfin, qu'on soit libres.
-Je veux que
tout le monde soit libre.
-Tu vois un gouvernement national
ou international ?
-National.
-Gouvernement international.
-Toute la terre,
il y aura une seule monnaie.
-Je crois que...
Il n'y aura pas de gouvernement
international, il y aura toujours..
..une division entre pays.
Peut-être certains petits pays..
..disparaîtront pour
se fondre en fédération.
-Tu vois un ou des pays ?
-Un pays.
-Un seul.
-Qui gouvernera ce monde ?
-L'Amérique.
-La Chine.
-Je ne sais pas.
Je pense que, quand même,
..la Russie c'est un pays
qui a de l'avenir.
-Qui va nous dériger ?
-Plusieurs chefs.
-Ce sera un Russe, un Américain,
un Français, un Anglais ?
-Un Russe.
-Où tu le vois
ce gouvernement du monde ?
-Dans un pays,
je ne sais pas...
La France, je la trouve très bien,
très jolie.
-A Rome, avec le pape.
-Ce sera un régime
de quelle forme ?
-Liberté sans être liberté.
-Une liberté bien dirigée ?
-Oui.
-Le chef sera un militaire
ou un civil ?
-Un civil.
-L'armée aura-t-elle
une grande importance ?
-Oui.
-Tu vois des pauvres
ou des riches ?
-Il y aura beaucoup plus
de riches, puisque comme..
..ils feront des études, ils
auront aussi une belle situation.
-Le patron existera encore
en l'An 2000 ?
-Bien sûr,
ça ne changera pas.
-Et toi, tu seras quoi ?
-Pauvre.
-Tu seras un patron ou un ouvrier ?
-Patron, j'espère.
-Ca t'es égal d'être ouvrier ?
-Oui, ça ne me fait rien.
Je travail et je ramène ma paye.
Je suis content.
-Comment ça marchera,
il y aura un patron ou pas ?
-Il n'y aura pas de patron.
-Ca sera toi le patron ?
-Non, quand même pas.
-Il y aura des patrons,
puis des ouvriers, c'est obligé.
-Et toi, tu seras quoi ?
-Un pauvre ouvrier...
-Pourquoi un pauvre ouvrier ?
-Je ne pourrai pas avoir...
pour apprendre.
-Il y a des patrons pour toi
en l'An 2000 ?
-Non, je n'aime pas les patrons.
J'aime mieux que tout le monde
soit égal, quoi.
-Il y aura plus de patrons
et moins d'ouvriers,
..puisque
tout se fera automatiquement.
-Tu aimerais vivre dans un monde
de patron ou d'ouvrier ?
-De patron.
-Et toi, tu serais quoi ?
-Patron.
-Et t'auras pas d'ouvriers ?
-Si, mais pas beaucoup.
Il y aura plus de machines.
-D'après toi, l'avenir
est à l'ouvrier ou au patron ?
-A l'ouvrier.
A tous les hommes.